shooting through the walls amazing
that's d8 joe pesci how do you guys
think they got this shot oh my god i
lost it in theaters when that happened
hi welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react we take a
look at some of the craziest vfx shots
in hollywood break down how they're done
and give them our own critiques as
visual effects artisan what maybe could
have been done to make them better or
perhaps what makes them so amazing to
begin with such classic reactions as oh
and
wow oh you missed oh there's also what
look at the neck
look at that neck
what is it
this is one of my favorite movies of all
time actually it's probably the best jet
sequence caught on film look at that
look there goes the smoke there
i got two missiles
right in the fireball it's gonna be a
weird looking fireball but whatever who
cares look at this shot
oh man okay let's take a look at how
they did this sequence dude for all the
jet stuff they dropped the camera man on
top of the tallest mountain and he
probably had like a thousand millimeter
lens and they just had this jet going
through this valley and it was really
smart to drop the guy on top of mountain
too because then you get the ground
behind the jet and you get motion blur
otherwise it's just the air and you
can't tell how fast it's moving that's
what makes this whole scene is the
live-action jet footage and the
intensity so when you add in your cg
missile it doesn't feel scg because most
of it is real and the smoke plume on a
missile is not super complicated in
terms of simulation you can just do it
with particles and puffs
[Applause]
that shot yes is that a miniature i
think it's got the scobby miniatures
there's no way that's cg in 2001
miniature tree yeah with an air blast
gun i think the way you could tell is if
does it feel like it was in slow motion
because miniatures are usually filmed in
slow motion to make them look big when
they move yeah
yeah it's got the slow motion vibes and
i think what is it's three miniature
trees on like a green or blue screen and
the background is a map from the actual
location yeah
so how do you guys think they got this
shot because they probably don't have a
film camera in a jet based off of some
of these other shots in the sequence i
think they had some miniatures and i'm
wondering if this is
a miniature set that they're getting
this plate with although it's totally
feasible though that they would simply
just take a helicopter and fly it
through this environment where they've
had the jet and just have some aerial
footage to work with yeah when i look at
the shot i see like the miniature wing
most likely and just a background plate
from the helicopter and then the
missiles dropped in
watch the clouds in this shot notice how
the clouds are moving all fast maybe
they had like an aerial shot a practical
one that they just wanted to speed up to
match the speed of the missile we're the
same issue in our superman with a gopro
video where superman needs to fly fast
and if you watch closing that video and
you look at the road you can see all the
cars speed up and slow down depending on
the speed that superman is flying
interesting
it all just looks very realistic they
definitely looked at their reference
footage and got it right so i look at
the statistics 40 of people watching
this still are not subscribed so if you
enjoyed the show please consider
subscribing it helps out a bunch all
those potential subscribers you guys are
making sam cry why aren't you subscribed
to the channel i've never seen sam cry
before it'd be really awkward if i did
so please subscribe to the channel and
to all you who are subscribed you're the
best
russell he he took a shine to me right
away the irishman it's another three and
a half hours of martin scorsese's irish
gangsters normally when you're watching
a movie with d aging in it they're
trying to actually make them look
younger but what's funny about the
irishman is that they bring them from
very old to old that's d-h joe pesci so
this is how old they are for real right
now
he's dead
what the heck
i'm saying in a case like this the best
thing to do is you use something brand
new when you
mess with someone's age whether you're
making them older or younger you are
creating a full cg version of that
character and comping them into a shot
it looks generally pretty good and i
would say most scenes actually in this
movie work really flawlessly it starts
looking a little weird when robert de
niro starts walking look at that like
floaty head yeah but like why is it i
think the really the telltale sign of
the cg face is all in the neckline
though because basically if deal with
the neck folds and stuff and paint out
and reconstruct stuff there and so you
kind of get this all too clean line no
no you don't owe me anything so the
challenge that ilm faced here is that
martin scorsese didn't want a bunch of
motion trackers and mocap suits he's
like listen i'm going to be on set i
don't want to see any of the technology
so what they did is every actor is being
filmed with three cameras simultaneously
so you have the real camera in the
center and it's flanked by two more
digital cameras they're getting three
perspectives on one object the actors
face and from that they can rebuild the
geometry the crazy thing is like the
camera rig is like this wide yeah it's
like three giant cameras the most
chunkiest of camera rigs i've ever seen
the lighting needs to be consistent for
this to work what they did is they
actually had ring lights that were
infrared so they just wash the scene in
infrared light and we can't see infrared
light and the main camera can't see an
infrared light only the reference
cameras the witness cameras are called
could see what's important about using
infrared light like that is that it
gives you a really evenly lit uh image
whereas like in these scenes there's
like harsh shadows and high key lights
if you have a 3d model that later you
want to be able to re-light it and have
it be flexible so you need that evenness
i'm just going to get the wine now
during this process in order to make
sure that their cg models accurately
looked like these characters they
actually ran a process it is basically
an ai based deep fake to get reference
frames if they'd pick a scene in the
movie the ai would give them a selection
of frames from other old movies and
media being like here's a picture of
robert de niro making the same
expression at the age you're looking for
under the lighting conditions they're
looking damn it wasn't used a comp it
was just used to compare for reference
please frank so you can capture three
model great you can re-target the
performance great you still need to
render it in your scene and so they're
going the tried and true like
mathematically based route of recreating
the lighting and for every new lighting
setup they plop a lidar in the middle of
the scene and do a quick scan of the
room to get the exact positioning of all
the lights then they capture an hdri so
the lighting ends up being perfectly
filled to real and ends up being a
perfect match it's just ingenious how
they're able to capture the performance
and rebuild a 3d model on set without
any tracking markers jeez man that
sounds like the way to go to be totally
honest less like high-tech junk you need
to have to deal with as an actor you
know you will get a better performance
because you can focus on the story et
cetera et cetera you know what i'm
noticing a severe lack of bad vfx we're
all about our cool vfx shots what about
the bad ones those are the fun ones yeah
i want your help please leave a comment
below telling us a bad effect from a
movie that you want us to respond to
[Music]
him upgrade a nice little sleeper hit of
an action movie made for four million
dollars really four million that's it
for four million dollars so quick
premise the guy's a quadriplegic and he
has a computer chip in his neck that's
controlling his body he's not
controlling his body at all so if he's
in a room fair on the bad guys the
computer is like do you want me to kill
the bad guys and he goes uh yes
thank you
such a cool effect i like how the
computer moves his head out of the way
so he doesn't get punched
[Music]
oh my god
dude i lost it in theaters when that
happened i screamed and then yeah same
same i know i got these scars
did you guys notice anything about the
camera moves yeah it moves with him
it's like how would you how would you
guys do this this doesn't seem to be
like a post stabilization effect because
the thing you always notice when it's
post stabilization is that the motion
blur doesn't line up so let's say you
have a shot where an actor is going like
this or their head back and forth right
then let's say you stabilize that so our
head stays locked in the frame but what
happens is you that motion blur is still
there so their face just becomes kind of
like weirdly horizontally smeared every
once in a while even if they're staying
locked down and that look isn't existing
here in upgrade so they're doing
something special so basically what they
did was they strapped an iphone to the
actor's chest the camera rig that they
were using could communicate with the
phone's gyroscope so when the phone goes
this way the camera goes this way and
you're getting all of that tracking done
in camera that's ingenious so you might
think all this crazy tech is just to
come up with some cool visuals and an
action scene but it actually serves a
story purpose the main character he's
disconnected from his body so it's all
about the world moving around him he
sits in one spot and his body moves and
it's such a great ingenious way to make
actions serve the story it's a cool
movie you should check it out
[Music]
dude that is sweet so cool looking i
love like just the weapon concept work
in this
all right we've gotta go faster
stabilization there's your stabilization
yeah motion blur yeah
i love how the plot of this movie is
like matt damon gets an exoskeleton and
then everything goes wrong
it's basically that
oh i love this
all right i'm gonna take a guess that
the door is already scored and then just
erasing the seams and then just pop out
the door this time so it's got to be
practical yeah you can see the
reflection of the ground on the shadow
oh look how it flexes when it hits the
ground yeah there's no way so they're
probably painting in the hot glow on the
door when it falls the sparks too i like
how he flips through the shape so that's
the best part yeah i'm surprised it's
not like a star shape though a heart
yeah a freaking heart
attack doors tech lights tech everything
tech damon
that's the best part
you're in the gun room take your guns
yes
shooting through the walls amazing this
is amazing
so his arm flies off there boom that's a
great that's a great effect i love how
you can see the bullet trails too yeah
the hard thing with bullets is like
showing motion like when movies just
show squibs going off it's just not as
impactful as showing exit wounds
trails like you need to show the
momentum of a bullet to give it impact
so that guy's just cg
i i don't know i feel like the guy's
probably real and they're just painting
out pieces of him but all they're
removing is his leg head and arms
oh boy
boss's face needs a fix-up
this is crazy the way it moves like the
way everything pops back into place dude
i think they actually built a prosthetic
charcoal copley head and they tore it
apart and reversed it in stop motion yes
because it does move like stop motion i
don't like look at the way the skin goes
around the eye i don't think it's a
prosthetic thing the overall motion of
it reminds me of every claymation video
i've ever seen all right here's nico's
final thesis on how this is done it's a
model like a crazy prosthetic wax model
they're doing cg on top of that to make
everything start to grow back in then
the light passes over us and now the
base layer is the clean footage of the
actor with some leftover images from
from the prosthetic and some of the cg
bits still on their comped on
growing back in and it's the motion
though that makes it so weird and that's
you know as if everything that motion
like really sells it neil went around
with claymation i know neil
boys those are some crazy visual effects
yeah yeah good ones
so we heard you guys questions about how
we make these videos and what tools we
use a main contributor in that is puget
systems this one gets me won the lottery
today who did you did dude
puget systems they make computers and
they're not just computers these are
high-end custom designed workhorses so
if you guys are interested in a computer
for yourself go check out the puget
systems website and they actually just
hooked up our editor dean with a
computer of his own so with this new
puget i'll finally be able to get rid of
carmichael's old computer you know
there's so much history in that computer
and so many great videos have been
edited on it but today is the day that
it'll finally be able to retire in peace
[Applause]
i'm sorry for this ejection sequence oh
the ejection sequence is so good
[Music]
all right found another clip that has
ejection sequins
i love this look at the hard drive
melting